I really really really really didn't get
to this point in my career on like
charisma or cuteness or by accident the
marriage between sales and branding is
very real on the internet and most
people are one or the other everybody
it's gary vaynerchuck back with an audio
experience episode this one's super fun
for me as many of you know I've been
building up my Tech's community to one
two nine three one five seven three one
for the kids at home and did a fun
little thing where I kind of blasted out
to the community of like I get into a
very like Santa Claus mode once in a
while where I just want to do random
stuff I think surprising like
serendipity chances such a exciting part
of life and so one I don't even recall
where I was probably well I probably no
question was flying or doing something
that wasn't in the office cuz I wouldn't
have time for it and I said somebody's
gonna get flown or in this case trained
enough to the office and be on the
podcast and we'll see what happens and
that is exactly what's happened here and
so we are here Dustin had a lot of
technical difficulties so that was a fun
seven-minute awkward situation while I
had to take out some business fires and
I really appreciate seriously you
sitting there with your friends nice and
calm so let's get into the episode so
the real punchline was questions I see
you were very prepared I see paper yes
why don't you tell the Vayner nation who
you are and how how this all happened
from your perspective I'd be happy to me
that story I'm excited oh well I'm
Theresa Stover and with me here I have
Larry Davis John Fitzpatrick and my
husband Rick Stover and I guess back in
October Shaun had let me know I'm a big
podcast fan I have a kid that goes to
Pittsburgh so I'm got four or five-hour
drives often so he turned me on to you I
started listening sort of following
started doing everything and I tweeted
that I am a female owner of a company
that it
was started by my father who was an
immigrant a son of an immigrant excuse
me we have multi-generational impacts
the things that I thought kind of
related to what you talk a lot about and
I was lucky enough to get picked however
I didn't know for about 48 hours realize
yes we had I have three kids we had a
crazy weekend with sports and my oldest
daughter who's a pit kept trying to call
me to tell me she didn't want me to do
it didn't want to do it over text and I
was blowing her off hard and so
everybody was listening so you know I
sent it out on text the community's
quite large
I had told everybody to use a hashtag
tell me their story Teresa stories very
good and much like most of you you know
a lot about me so every reply on Twitter
was quite good you know I'm gonna help
you buy the Jets let's talk about sports
car it's like every book button is
getting pushed and like to be very
honest and I'll continue to do surprises
like my whole life it is all serendipity
it is just wild serendipity like of
course something catches your eye to
make the decision but it's much more
than the subconscious like I'm not
clicking accounts or there's no like
data being thrown at it it is like me
making a subjective call and so and the
way I do it is that I reply to that
person because it's done on Twitter so
what's easy for me when I do this is I
reply that person see see my team on it
and then go on my merry way and then one
day randomly that person shows up and
that's what was happening so I reply to
you on Twitter but you're so crazy you
don't see it your daughter sees it she
but she wants to deliver the news so
here you are so busy
you're not even answering your own
daughter which by the way I love and
response we're like if she's not saying
911 see you're like yeah I'll catch up
with her later I just love that to begin
with but keep going well so we were at
my son's football game and she kept
calling sight and Rick aunts is I gotta
get the column I put the phone down you
know we're here to watch Eli and he gets
it you know anything is your son no Eli
Stover I understand so anyhow we get the
news and then of course I completely
ignore Eli's game and look at my phone
as
I hope not to do but it was for a very
good and exciting reason so you actually
picked up the phone and she tells you
and then you go look at well no he did
he didn't he's like you won the contest
and I was like what are you talking
about oh my gosh so then of course and I
had gotten a million tweets and you know
all kinds of stuff so my phone had blown
up but I have all my notifications
turned off certain weekends and things
so yeah so a day or so later I figured
it out and of course now we're here
that's awesome yeah
when did when was it he was like October
yeah October so here we are so what do
you wanna do with this time well um what
I'd love to do is tell a little bit
about my family's business lease and
then you know the reason Larry's here
Sean of course is why you he's the whole
reason why we're here and of course he's
my nephew and Rick anyhow I'd love to
tell a little bit about the company and
then open up to questions for you if
that's okay I'm here for you okay great
so I mentioned Larry's our marketing
director he took over and started
working with us about six months ago
he's a background in retail and I spent
his entire career in marketing he's made
an immediate impact since joining the
company which is great and what kind of
company is it we are a home improvement
company so exterior home improvement
roofing siding windows doors gutters and
just to the end consumer yes understood
sean is during the company two years ago
in sales he's risen from new kids
selling over a million in his first year
to our number two sales person overall
selling 1.7 million and in 2019 so he's
killing it and he is a sales person
since you're going to consumer is doing
what closing deals so there's 30 of us
that are coming from your your outbound
calling and all inbound because the
reputation we know generation that
sounds like more like 40 years in
business forty nonetheless 40 you have a
brand locally so your inbound enquiries
need to be converted yeah among other
things
yeah cold out reaching in sales or is it
is so the website or the phone call or
whatever other top of the funnel
behavior doing comes and then you're
converting inquiry or questions into
potential business understood so
my dad started the company a million
years ago as we said 1980 but a little
bit about it maybe not be a millionaire
so pretty clearly but over New Jersey
yeah kindergarten school that I was in
the 1980 good I'm so the interesting
thing about him which i think is part of
why we got here is his he was a fifth
child of an Irish American family his
generation was a first generation to be
born here of his family so that his dad
was an engineer came here because there
was no work right so he went to went to
high school graduated was married at 19
was in college and had myself my sister
by the time he was 21 and was doing
roofing and siding work on the side old
school ship yes and realized that maybe
college wasn't wanting to do need to
provide for his family so he started
subcontracting ended up starting his own
business it's cool so you know part of
why or we the whole reason why the
company is where it is today is because
my dad is a man of integrity all the
decisions he made through the years were
made because he wanted to he named the
company after himself and and reputation
so oh the game yes so he I can't say
enough great things about him he was
involved until about 11 years ago when
Rick and I bought out bought out his
company is your dad alive he is he's
retired is he's listening to this
podcast right now he will be when I send
it to him his name Pete Fitzpatrick Pete
great [ __ ] job so one thing that my
dad instinctively knew how to do was to
provide great customer service along
with all the other great things that he
did and even as a young child I knew
that and I felt connected to the
business I was the oldest I was always
at a side I would be there for he'd take
me to afternoon appointments I was under
the desk I would try to sneak in if he
said I can't go to an appointment I try
to sneak in the back of his truck
I don't was get in trouble so I've
always felt really connected to the
business however I didn't join the
business except for small roles I did in
college which I gave out flyers I would
call back his appointments do things
like that but I didn't actually join the
business full-fledged until just under
40
years ago yes I came on to help and
recruiting now Rick on the other hand my
husband got involved eighteen years ago
and he left a job in banking took the
leap to the family business and he's
worked in various roles working his way
up to GM and till we bought the business
eleven years ago very cool so I
understand everything so far yeah so
fast-forward to now we have 110
employees we do over 30 million in sales
from all the work we talked about all of
our work has a lifetime warranty we take
great pride in the company and our
culture this is just from I continue to
context this is the service provider of
these things right you know you don't
sell any branded items like you don't
have a gutter with your company's name
on it
you're the service provider yeah I
understand that keep going so we about
regional is it like it's Delaware
Delaware Valley so we're fat we cover
four states four counties in
Pennsylvania and most of Delaware part
of Maryland part of Jersey
I understand but let's see so my goal is
to get your help on our marketing our
overall marketing strategy that we are
using as a traditional strategy print
Direct Mail commercials Google Adwords
we recently dipped our toe into the
Facebook poll last month prior to that
though and well in October Shawn and I
started using your philosophy which is
we've started really trying to ramp up
our social media so we're now on
Facebook Instagram Twitter Linkedin
YouTube we were already on Facebook and
YouTube
we had wanted a more thoughtful like
you're taking it more seriously
we took a try guess they took a shot at
it a few years back it's all the time
and didn't see any results didn't think
it was working and abandoned it make
sense so now we're really giving it a
try
we've watched well a couple reasons
I and this is really where I want to
have these guys talk as well and I
really feel like what our customer base
tends to skew a little bit older so
especially for our bath products exam I
also think because we didn't see any
results we could they it was abandoned
so everyone saw it as like a fun nice to
have
necessary I understand so we've of
course seen a huge increase in
engagement since we started it's it's
gone great but what we're here to find
out is how do you connect us since
there's right um since there's no way to
track anything but engagement well there
that's not true
since the strategy was set up to only
track engagement you're not struggling
with the notion of does it lead to sales
well I'm not necessarily as you
intuitively believe it because you're
the son of a father who built a business
on word-of-mouth and social is
predicated on the same nuances right
same nuance it's not the same same
nuances you know very easy for pops back
in the day hello there's this voice is
gonna get fresh by poachers hello hello
is this you pee
yeah I'm mr. Thompson on Delaware Street
and Delaware my friend Rick told me
you're awesome can you work here very
easy for him to know word of mouth works
when you don't have a human on the other
side of that lead that came in you don't
know if that was print or direct mail or
radio or television or social or Google
AdWords unless you strategize it to do
that it's very easy for you to post
something right now on Facebook that
creates us that you can create a
separate Google phone number a Google
Voice number do the ability to track it
is those are so so you did every piece
of content on Facebook and I had a phone
number on it
not then not even if not even throwing
the right hook just having the phone
number there you would then be able to
see the data on which phone numbers came
in from that number and which one of
those converted into his 1.7 in sales
hmm it's actually shockingly exciting to
me most people to your point and by the
way ninety-nine point seven percent of
businesses let alone small businesses
and by the way for everybody listening
thirty is insane it's a real [ __ ]
business but I'm talking corporate talk
small businesses don't set it up to be
able to measure it so you're saying that
we it's the most trackable thing because
it's happening on the internet it just
have you have to have a strike if you're
a organization that is
desperate to see results on every dollar
in the short-term which at some level
everybody is it all depends on how much
money you are have like you have the
luxury of thinking long-term so I'm sure
back to the history of this business by
listening you're okay with it truly
paying out for real three years from now
because you're not looking to flip it
tomorrow right so yeah I mean I just
gave you the direct example of how easy
it is to measure everything you could
have a separate phone number for YouTube
Twitter Facebook like you could like
it's so measurable it's actually
uncomfortable you know we do do that we
what's hard for us numbers guys to to
get wrap around our brain is is the
specific posts that are really will the
jab so to speak and you know the jabs
aren't ads obviously the good news is
the jabs and I appreciate using my
terminology so flattered in theory can
be so inexpensive they cost less than
the stamps you do on your direct mail so
it depends on how you're quantifying the
cost against your jabs the other thing
that is very challenging is for you guys
to really get to the numbers game you
have to turn off the other advertising
and suffocate advertising to see what's
working what's not my my belief is that
you're making assumptions on things
you've done historically then and you're
putting them and you're putting the new
stuff through a scrutiny that you
haven't done for the other stuff because
it's been accepted and you know ads on
Facebook phone numbers I see so you're
you're more having a scrutiny around the
organic content the question I wrestle
with is Teresa's content is hugely
engaging as we get a lot of her the
human or what she managed hosting you
the human so we're getting lots of jobs
we're getting lots of you know likes and
shares are you getting qualitative
feedback like are you getting comments
on Tom yes okay but they're not
necessarily related to
it's a roofing roofing is a pretty tough
subject to get social engagement around
I mean it's like you could post videos
about mold growing on your roof and it's
not gonna generate a lot of response but
the key issue is yeah to your point like
I'd rather get zero comments and likes
and get two customers from a video I
make about a moldy roof on Facebook than
to do a ton of things that get all the
comments in the world and lead to
nothing
to your point also all that stuff that's
being said and all that engagement is
actually probably leading to business it
just might be hidden and that's what
you're trying to tackle for us can I
give you a great recommendation that
works for this scenario all the time why
don't you guys make a decision on costs
on the jabs and organic make one number
financially that appeases the numbers
guys and appeases the jabs and gray
people and move on your merry way the
things I've always done for brand and
long term if I decide I'm going to spend
forty seven thousand dollars on it and I
need zero ROI on return I've already won
because I'm not having debates with the
people that are looking at the numbers
we've both all collectively agreed that
we're gonna make this forty seven
thousand dollar investment and we're not
gonna be emotional about that and as
long as we stay within how we quantify
that away we go and thus you're spending
no mind time to debate you've made an
investment in brand it could be 0 ím
unemotional about that but what it does
is it puts in a frame where you don't
have to worry about the organic ROI of
it in a world where you may have people
that believe in brand or the subtleties
of it or believe intuitively it's
working versus ones that want to put a
quantifiable number against it and when
47 and if it's 25 thousand as long as
like if you just take your overall
marketing mix and decide to take five
points out for branding and that becomes
the budget then there's no tension in
the system and everyone can go on their
merry way unless the great people want a
lot more money than you're willing to
allocate and I think maybe even
measuring so the the the posts that
Teresa does don't really cost us
anything other than her tell my time
which is the best [ __ ] business of
all time I would I would argue then if
that's true
why are we even debating it if the cost
is zero part of it is maybe could we do
it better so it does more tie into our
business as their ways too and those are
ways to tie what we do not just you know
tie our traditional with the social
forget about traditional I think it's
more about what you're trying to
actually accomplish right like I think
it's less passionate about traditional
or digital I think it's more about how
do we you know there's many questions
here one do you want to do that or are
you enjoying this is now a human
question let alone an executive question
you got a mold to human and the
executive in a family business like I'm
enjoying doing it my concern is we do to
skew older and they're not gonna be
around forever and I am concerned that
as Millennials of they're becoming the
more the homeowners we are my concern is
we're not engaging them in the same way
we are the the boomer generation and I
think this is a great way to potentially
accomplish something that way I would
say probably has nuances of both what I
would argue is that first of all
Facebook is more effective right now for
me with 55 to 75 than direct mail and
newspaper from my dad's business and
most of the businesses that are SMBs
that I care about so a the greatest
thing you should definitely do like
there's a lot of conversations going on
here let's break them down the a B test
against your newspaper strategy is
really interesting to me facebook done
here's my facebook in theory if you have
the creative capabilities will beat
newspaper and the dynamic that we just
talked out no matter how low the cost of
that newspaper ad in a hundred different
places what the phone number is
Facebook's advantage is two things in
the eight you know we spend about a
billion in media so this is coming from
that context and we look at it we don't
you know when we work with big brands
we're still going local as hell right
what you definitely need to do if you're
doing that much print is test the same
exact demo against newspaper if that
newspaper ad is costing you a eight
hundred twelve hundred dollars running
eight to twelve hundred dollars against
a piece of creek what the reason
Facebook always wins
when done when both are done perfect is
that
in Cherry Hill New Jersey I could make a
reference to the Giants and the Jets and
the Eagles and that can hit three demos
we're on Facebook at 140 bucks each
against those fan bases where as in
print you'll have to pick one of them
it's the creative flexibility of
Facebook and then my general opinion
that there's more consumption actually
seeing it versus the print ad on page
142 that to me is probably the most
interesting except if I bought the
business the marketing dollar a be
tested by the way though I think things
skew this way at costs it's not about is
one better the other I just care about
what something costs my favorite ad to
buy in the world is a television spot
it's called the Superbowl cost six
billion dollars we bought three of them
for clients this year like I'm very
excited about the three Super Bowl spots
that one really excites me because
that's very measurable for this
organization so that's just one random
thing cuz it does skew older and you can
by the way a video of how to as a as the
ad versus the print picture like I know
for a fact that if you built a machine
that got really good at local facebook
ads it would grow your business having
the capability of creating the content a
low enough cost is very real there's
unlimited $15 an hour creators that
would much rather have it even at a
boring roofing company would much rather
make videos than work somewhere else not
making videos because they're creative
the entire ecosystem of twenty eighteen
to thirty right now wants to be creative
and so that's one thing to debate the
cost of your creative lowering it by
going minimum wage what's Delaware's
better wage right there's a lot of
twelve-year-old - excuse me a lot of
child labor is a great there's a lot of
people who are so fortunate that they
can afford to or so hungry to live their
passion to do to work making videos on
route like it they just exist so there's
a lot on that as far as the you build if
you became me if you became me which who
I am right now is I have a lot of young
people fans of me what would still
happen if you have five million fans on
Instagram and Facebook you as a
collective would try to understand
what the ROI of that is for your
business and the reality is is that at
scale I think it's a I think you doing
you the way I'm hearing so far is more
like salt and pepper not the steak okay
there'll be some nice nuances the reason
I if you notice the cadence of my
questions if you like it I'm already
happy cuz then you'll do it with a
different vigor that will lead to good
stuff it will but to drive the business
you need a scalable model to take
advantage of these platforms not to rely
on a personal brand who's not going
direct at the prime given example my
content now leads to less business for
vaynermedia than my content for Wine
Library led when I'm a hundred trillion
times bigger why because in 2008 when I
was making a wine video it was so direct
to the business I was in that it led to
business whereas now the 99 percent of
my audience is not vaynermedia clientele
got it yes yeah now do I believe that
you're gonna inspire some other female
entrepreneur in Delaware on a post yes I
do and do I feel like on next Thursday
if she needs a new roof or whatever else
you're selling bathroom like that you
can into consideration yes I do
there will be business but if we're
talking about scalable hey by the time
you get to a size as big as me that's
real time and work and talent and B I
don't want you to miss out on the actual
opportunity in social which is some of
the stuff I led to on the newspaper a B
test that I just talked about yeah if I
was if I was the family member to join
or teammate I would say hey I love your
guys spirit but I'd be okay if we did
know organic and we ran paid against
everything I would rather you run paid
against female entrepreneurs in Delaware
against your content for a hundred bucks
to amplify top of the funnel and brand
than to just leave it at organic okay
mainly because the ads are so under
priced cuz they're gonna get more
expensive Facebook was uncomfortably a
good deal five years
no uncomfortably it's starting to get to
where Google is which is get
appropriately priced I built on Google
AdWords I'm gonna be wearing weird I
spent five cents a click well so that
was one of the questions we did want to
find out from you as that's right you
know what you would suggest what
platforms you would suggest for a
business like ours
your company should be doing 10 pieces
of content a day on LinkedIn that is how
to LinkedIn and again content versus
paid advertising I mean I know that's
funny
and I'm glad look LinkedIn is actually a
very organic platform so LinkedIn is
kind of wild it's one of these one
places where you can have no account
like you probably have now post and
actually people will see it but somebody
might see in st. Louis mm-hmm LinkedIn's
ad products a little expensive but I
like that you can target things you
could target specific businesses you
could look at who is using your product
and have like a feel there might be a
major company only a mile from you guys
and all the employees live in the
surrounding suburbs so there's a lot of
strategy like I'll give you one you
could target Campbell's soups employees
right big company in Camden not too far
from sounds like it's in your demo today
and then your video is like hey do you
work at Campbell's soup that alone has
already got you in the mix that's the
flexibility of social that print and and
and radio don't have you you're stuck to
one creative in the old world you could
have the game for this is the volume of
contextual creative at scale well we
really need to like those kind of ads
you're not looking to do hey $99 for a
month for a new bath you're funny I
wouldn't be scared to play a B and by
the way if you're cheeky about it and
you have fun with it it's a little less
douchey I think you can really get away
with it I think they're they're a
different measure ability aspect is like
like I've watched yourself forever so
like and I'd like my initial argument is
like like not only will they sometimes
people don't call the number you put
Facebook right so measurability we don't
know that they're talking to their their
seeing our stuff and then they're
talking to their never and then they're
throwing throwing brand versus sales is
it is the forever challenge when I see
this scenario where there's all good
intent which is already thank God you
know you're you guys are on third and
fourth fifth space I think I think you
have a real conversation around what I
said I think if you have a sales
marketing bucket and a brand marketing
bucket everybody's gonna be much happier
if you guys agree to a set number of
dollars - we don't need - like I I doubt
that the two guys behind you don't
believe in brand well we have a whole
brand name two-part course so so what
needs to happen is don't blend the lines
you make one core budget and you are
cruising I've seen it a million times
I've seen the most contentious mom and
daughter father and son family business
small businesses executives the most
contentious scenarios where I literally
laid out this out and like literally a
week later I get an email like you saved
our life we would argue all day long and
now that it's just 18,000 for a year
Carol's pumped she's gonna spend it how
about like if I'm the quant and money
and math guys I say to the art or brand
people I'm like go put it on black I
don't give a [ __ ] it's like I do like
teeny budget of a nerd
once I set how much you have for
traveling expenses take a [ __ ] rocket
ship [ __ ] you have all year to spend
this you spend it you want to take a
train did you take the Acela did you
take that I don't give a [ __ ] like I
don't want to judge you along the way
here's the macro budget go I don't need
to micromanage you so I think that could
really work what questions do you have
Larry Rick I just want to get back to
the that degrees with the post where
there were only organic on tick-tock and
LinkedIn yes at this exact moment in
time okay four years ago Facebook
organic hell yes five years ago four
years ago had organic Instagram hell yes
here's how they all start they all start
once they hit organic is a dream but you
can't control where it goes right and if
you have an arrow business then the ad
product come
and it's a dream because it's a
marketplace and you bid it up and the
cheapest [ __ ] then that becomes properly
priced and then it becomes overpriced
and it never becomes as overpriced is
print radio and television because they
set floors based on their margin
marketplaces are fair its supply and
demand but that's how the market goes
Burleigh is organic non controllable
where you go if you're narrow but if
you're just doing building macro brand
great for me I want everybody to
underpriced add product that's where
instagrams stories are right now you
want to get younger and you want to
convert sales you guys should run an
ungodly amount of Instagram story ads
interims story the main feed Instagram
product is getting close to being
properly priced the story ads where you
can swipe up and land on the website
great for the guys behind you because
they're gonna see the lead gen and great
for you guys because it's super under
price $3 CPMs in delaware opening line
of the videos hate I just literally did
it a couple hours ago my office hey la
hey like contextual creative okay
always always it's why this is all
happening the reason they've I would
with you guys I mean what the Penn
Station out go back to Delaware and an
82 year old man would ask for a selfie
and a 13 year old girl would ask for
selfie and an african-american and a
Latino and a white is because I'm
contextual across all platforms I'm cool
to 12 year old girls on tik-tok and I'm
cool for 64 year old executives on
LinkedIn why cuz I put different content
out it's still me I'm not making it up I
just know what to talk about to the
audience because that's why they would
be interested by just starting the
videos hey are you a Campbell's employee
and they are because you use the
targeting on LinkedIn you've already got
a prayer go drive and film it in front
that nice new Campbell's building and
you're already even more connection
because they'll see the visual it's all
content this is contextual contextual
warfare not content warfare content is
what everybody focuses on the nuance
under that is contextual content at
scale you need to invest in making a lot
of content content is king
that's right that's right
and when you put those two together and
you have a business result you're off to
the races
did you I have a couple quick things
videos and real quick culture right so
like when Joe Flacco retires you make a
head nod to Delaware football like like
things know things right videos how
important do you think they are versus
pictures or is that different on every
you can make a six-second vine it's the
same way I think about length creative
is the variable of success okay I make
videos that are [ __ ] two hours long
and people watch them I have eight hour
vlogs on YouTube people watch and then
there's videos I put out that are 39
seconds and no do well because it wasn't
good enough so the length or the format
is irrelevant
meaning video does extremely well we all
know that people enjoy it but there's a
lot of people who want to read it or
pictures like they could all work that
has more to do with you then it's not
the format it's the ability of one to
communicate on the format okay
okay did you have any questions just
like personally so I mean you've almost
watched too much content you already
know all the answers ya know so for me
so I'm in this situation kind of like
what you were in with your dad like I'm
doing your hardest job yeah I'm 25 yes
putting in a lot of hours yes like and
just try to absorb that's why I'm here
I'm absorbing everything and yes I'm
really lucky that they're willing to
listen to me
yeah a lot you know go back and forth
minutes huge but just like so the recent
men really like for me what do you think
the type of stuff I should be working on
and you know from so many highs I'm sure
business like this my intuition is the
quicker you can get from ideology to
practicality the better it's gonna be I
think the thing that really made me
successful that I always worry about
when people watch me and then are in
such situations is it always came
everything I talk about comes from
actual business results right and so the
vulnerability without knowing anything
about you is when you're seeing what I'm
talking about I talk about
and marketing I talk about building Nike
not a sales team so when you see that
and you start framing up my model when
you go enter the real world I don't talk
as much about operations and sales which
I equally do to me they're more
commoditized than building brand so my
worry is you come in and you come in
with ideology and they're like that's
cute but what the [ __ ] does that mean
for our business I know how to
articulate that to what it means in 12
or 24 months for real and show
indicators my dad was the hardest of all
he was an immigrant that was scared to
spend anything on anything he luckily -
was willing to give me a shot I had a
[ __ ] deliver so I mixed sales and
branding now it sounds like you two
really good salesmen things I use that
as leverage like you promised them that
you can do two point one next year and
because of that
give me another thirty thousand to do
market you know what I mean that
practicality do you see anything around
the bend like obviously we know social
media is not going away but it but it is
it's morphed from yes Facebook to
LinkedIn to whatever are you doing any
radio no we do TV but not radio you do
Rabbinate television no like cable TV in
broadcast long as mostly oh I love that
that's great that excites me I'm telling
you get get into it you leap here look
at each other
that was nice he was nice that was good
contextual creative at scale if you're
spending TV budget you don't you can't
imagine what your opportunity is once
you realize what that TV product is
versus YouTube and Facebook video when
you make contextual creative so this is
very simple business terms it make it
simple if you're spending a thousand
dollars to amplify that commercial and
you spent a thousand dollars to make
that commercial
let's just play that commercials vanilla
to the person on the other side you had
to be brought mm-hmm yeah you had to you
you're actually in it oh I'm Anna - okay
well this amount exceeding because you
guys are attractive so it's now I know
converting no but honestly ready for
this literally the life I just lived
literally if you started a video with
Wilmington listen to us right Philly
Harrisburg you know like Cherry Hill
Morristown New Jersey we've been and
like when you get into that it kills and
when you realize that Facebook video and
YouTube video and soon to be pre-roll on
OTT platforms where you can buy it like
a stock market you you I'm so happy
right now I think you'd sell buy my
excitement
you are wasting real money on television
not because it's not working cuz you're
like no vir you're wrong we've getting
these sales I'm like that's fine just
like you would say to him that's a cute
biology I would say to you that's cute
now let me show you what you can do with
that eighty thousand bucks where you'll
pour it back to the analogy I said that
thousand dollars is getting you a
certain amount results on the media
spent you spent two thousand to make it
happen I know that that same thousand on
YouTube and Facebook would be better and
that the content you made might cost you
2008 for videos at five hundred bucks
instead of one at a thousand but I know
the results would play because he made a
contextual mm-hmm and it was seen more
on the videos quality I mean can you
shoot them on an iPhone yeah yeah you
don't need you do know that there's a
YouTube pre-roll product that's based on
people search right you know that we can
run a pre-roll YouTube video of somebody
who's gonna watch an Eagles highlight on
YouTube but the pre-roll is you guys
because you know they live in the area
and they searched roof yeah they
searched renovating my bathroom I don't
think we know I promise you I know you
guys very well enough I knew you're
gonna like that brother
you know why it's mixed it's mixing
sales and Brett listen I can phone them
wrong for that particular cheerio I
promise you I promise you this and this
is a good thing to say to all four of
you I really really really really didn't
get to this point in my career on like
charisma or cuteness or by accident the
marriage between sales and branding is
very real on the internet and most
people are one or the other
[Music]
mm-hmm I mean one of the other one sales
or you're either all about sales where
you're all about Brandt
that's our industry right now to like
what's the world probably talking about
industry is all about saying yes so
transactional it's good news any small
business that sells something is all
about sales that's why they stay small
it's very real and I see that coming
from the small business I'm build a
business from three to sixty five
million with no money none you spend a
little bit more budget was $18,000 for
the year and I did in five years because
I know what happens when you marry brand
and marketing and my end at sales and
marketing my great fortune was that the
internet just happened and so the price
of email and Google search was so zero
that I milked the [ __ ] out of it I
learned that that got into pattern
recognition that's why I invested in
Facebook and Twitter and Tumblr because
I knew it was email and search all over
again in a new form but this time I got
smart invest in the companies not just
milked it and that's why I am Who I am
now that's why I'm never wrong I don't
talk until it's been proven I'm not
guessing I'm tick-tock there's a billion
[ __ ] users may not sell roofs but
what you need to always be prepared for
is maybe the way you make content on
tick-tock becomes the way you make
content you know more importantly I
always get worried in a good way that's
a slang term for interested when it's
super young because when it's 12 13 14
you suck in more grandparents than you
think
so I was so right about Facebook what I
knew about Facebook in 2007 when
everybody thought it was a college thing
was wait a minute these people are
posting their photos on there and their
parents and grandparents want to see
their photos mm-hmm so just psychology
last question I had sorry and you've
probably answered this already again so
when we're running ads though they
should be about us and our products and
what we sell but you need to try and
make them hit the person you're truly
talking to by
either making an interesting or
specificity aware you know cancer at
Camden or what okay who you like
American football if at all
we're Eagles fans Eagles you wearing an
eagle jersey in the beginning of the
video and running it on Facebook against
Eagle fans that live in Delaware right
the visual already sold you more product
money in the bank and if you're sellout
yeah because you're just about business
and [ __ ] football yeah and the next
video you wear a giant's Jersey context
at scale what nobody understands is it's
not about spending more media dollars
it's about spending more money on
content creation to create the context
to lower the cost of transaction because
you made it relevant mm-hmm the internet
lets you do that television print and
radio didn't which is why people didn't
think that way got it yeah we couldn't
afford it if I ran it all to I couldn't
afford six different Direct Mail
creatives you made one because it was
expensive and then you went to all the
zip codes mmm Facebook lets you do it
Instagram lets you do it YouTube lets
you do it the big one and this is why
it's so important to you I want you to
get good at this because we're only five
years away from Hulu and Amazon fire
stick and Netflix and the new television
doing programmatic contextual buying I
can run a commercial in Amazon fire
stick based on somebody who bought
gutter equipment when they're watching
friends on Amazon fire stick and live in
Delaware guys I'm telling you this is
not a joke this is real ass [ __ ] but
it's the marriage of the four of you got
it yeah
do we have anything else before we wrap
up I did I did want to say one thing um
you always give everyone a hard time for
not listening we have been listening
we've been we've been reading your books
we've been we started doing exactly what
you said so I wanted you to know that
people do listen I know that I
appreciate that and more importantly I
really appreciate the four of you
because this is going to be one of the
best piece of content I've ever put out
because the framework of what your
dynamic is is actually probably the
single most important conversation of
meaningful small businesses in America
today you guys are in the exact
crossroads that millions of people are
and and just watching the four of you in
this meeting
it excites me because you have to
understand your world is far more my
truth than almost anything the Sasha
group agency I have that's the place to
actually work with for everybody's
listen because that's what I did I took
something small and made it bigger with
not chase and Budweiser budgets and I
know exactly how to do it and I yeah
it's practical its pride its business
mmm Lincoln organic is gonna work for
you but Facebook I'm telling you guys
you target 50 to 70 year olds in your in
those five Burt in Delaware Valley you
will just and you make 113 videos on
your iPhone yeah and you have a fun day
like you're gonna have a fun and then
when you open up the kimono and you
don't want to wear to the Giants Jersey
but like Paul and accounting is a Giants
fan and we throw him in it like it will
wort land Glenn Glenn fine good news
you're in thank you everybody who's
listening to podcasts listen to this
four times if you run a small business
doing one 250 million dollars a year
it is the unlock interest thanks for
being here
you